scary fun was the motto for one of the
startups i worked for back in the day
many who choose to create and build
organizations can surely relate to this
idea
hello i'm matt abrahams and i teach
strategic communication at stanford
graduate school of business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
i am incredibly excited and honored
today to chat with steve blank steven is
an adjunct professor at stanford in the
department of management science and
engineering he teaches courses on lean
startups innovation and entrepreneurship
he is credited with launching the lean
startup movement and is the author of
the four steps to the epiphany the
startup owner's manual
and holding a cat by its tail
welcome steve thanks for having me matt
uh you've been an entrepreneur for over
45 years founding or co-founding eight
businesses and helping countless others
you mentioned this lean startup
methodology can you summarize that
approach and what it looks like and and
what are some best practices included in
it well matt that's usually a semester
class but i'll try to do it so cut me
off
right we'll take the cliff notes version
if you don't mind left notes version
basically says and and it's it's so
obvious it's like duh but we didn't
quite process it
is that there are no facts inside your
building so get the heck outside right
and what i mean by that is if you
remember what i said is startups used to
believe is all they needed to do is
write a plan and raise some money and
now execute per the plan why because if
the plan was funded well you know vcs
and god have blessed that plan
those aren't hypotheses those are facts
right people gave you money for them so
let's go build it the lean method simply
says look you have a set of hypotheses
it's okay you're out of on day one a
startup is a faith-based enterprise but
we want to turn it into facts as rapidly
as possible and no facts inside your ins
exist inside your building are very few
and if you're in sales or marketing it's
impossible to be smarter than the
collective intelligence of your
potential customers sitting in your
building so let's go out and test these
hypotheses so piece one of the lean
startup is a formal methodology called
customer development let's go do these
things to validate who are the customers
what features do they want pricing do
they want competitors
you know etc
but while we're doing that something
else
evolved in the 21st century and that's
the way to build products using
something called agile engineering
that is let's build products iteratively
and incrementally rather than using a
waterfall method which is a write the
spec build the product go through alpha
test beta test first customer ship if
you use agile instead you could be
building wireframes or tests or
spreadsheets or something to put in
front of customers very early on or
potential customers and get their
feedback and then take that back and and
say well wait a minute was there
assumptions correct
so agile engineering is part two
of the lean startup and then finally
what hypotheses should you be testing i
just mentioned some of them it turns out
that someone named alexander osterwalder
had put together something called
business model canvas and that's a
pretty good roadmap of the nine things
you need to worry about when you're
building a new venture not all of them
but it gets about 80 to 90
now in fact lean is those three
components customer development agile
engineering and business model uh design
that was an amazing crash course thank
you uh you got the whole semester you
know there we go i need to take my class
i was just gonna say send me the final
exam i'm ready to graduate i i like the
way you you package that up and faith to
fact i think is a really interesting way
to to think about it generating
hypotheses testing them with people who
actually might want to buy your product
what a brilliant idea and then this
notion of rapid iteration and
prototyping uh critical as well
i have a
a hypothesis i'd like to run by you so
part of what you discussed as the lean
methodology is this notion of minimally
viable product design where you you test
for user requirements you understand at
least a have some hypotheses about the
market come up with some wireframes and
then test and iterate
i feel that that same process can apply
to our communication as well it's about
as you said understanding your audience
it's about understanding the context in
which the messages need to be created
and deployed it's about structuring
those messages much like you would build
a wireframe of a product or service and
then you iterate and test
does the concept of minimally viable
communication resonate with you at all i
think that's a key tenet of everything i
teach about communications
you know for a startup
and i don't mean to dis on these folks
but hiring a pr agency too early is a
sign that
the ceo is treating this as someone
else's problem for me in a startup the
first pass the minimum viable product of
understanding audience message media and
messenger can only be done with the
founders and ceo engaged that is even if
they think they know nothing
about any of this stuff
i want them to actually get out of the
building and figure this out why because
they'll get it wrong and whatever but
but they'll have a feel a fingertip feel
now of oh let's this is our stake in the
ground now let's hire professionals who
could do this but we've built our own
mvps with in fact the people who best
know the product and think they know the
rest of these things it makes a much
better relationship
with a agency and the founders who
typically never get engaged in this part
of the business to actually have to have
done it themselves and i don't mean six
months of this but i mean uh you know a
couple weeks of trying to figure this
out i make them draft those audience
message messengers and media
draft themselves and then when they're
interviewing an agency they could say
well this is what we found tell us
what's wrong or how do we do this better
and usually good agencies could add huge
value here but at least they're talking
to an educated founding team who
appreciates what the language means and
the value excellent so getting your your
hands dirty as a founder and really
understanding the the impact and
importance of that communication can
serve you well
when you then go get professional help
to help move things forward and let me
let me double down why because smart
ceos treat communications as a force
multiplier a tool to dramatically
increase sales or valuation and the v or
the vehicles to get acquired lined up at
the door
you know not so successful ceos treat it
as a tactic that could be handed to
others and that's the difference for me
about where where marketing and
marketing communications needs to sit in
the early days of the company if the
founder's never been engaged
you're never going to get high quality
communications and i think you know the
canonical or the the pinnacle of this
was steve jobs you know he was engaged
this to him wasn't some other thing that
you handed to someone else you know he
was constantly engaged and apple had
some of the most brilliant marketing of
the 20th and 21st century absolutely and
it still reverberates today i'd like to
dig a little deeper into the role of
communication and how have you seen
communication play not just in marketing
and selling of products and ideas
but within organizations in terms of
teams etc what best practices or advice
and guidance have you seen that can
really make a difference with regard to
communication
boy do we have another semester i mean
stop it's not me when when we run out of
run out of air time but
you know let me start with even today
people tend to make the the same
mistakes about marketing and
communications
and startups as i did when i was a young
entrepreneur they number one is they
often confuse communications tactics
what should my web page look like or
should i be using facebook or instagram
with a strategy
you know a communication strategy at
least for me answers you know a couple
questions why are we doing these
activities for example and i'll give you
for example these happen to be my four
but we could make us some others is is
our communication strategy designed to
create demand for our products and drive
them into a sales channel or
and or are we trying to create awareness
of our company and brand for potential
customers so we try to educate
and position the company are we trying
to create awareness for fundraising that
is gee we're out raising money and we
want we're hoping that we could get the
attention of some folks or do we want to
create awareness for potential acquirers
so
once you've figured out the why you're
creating the strategy i just gave you a
list of
mine
then you need to figure out the how
there's just four steps
one is understand your audience number
two is what's the message for that
specific audience
so we got audience and we got a message
three is what's the media you want the
message to be read or seen or heard on
and then four is
who's the messenger
you want to carry
your message
i think that's really really helpful to
break it down into those ways there's a
very simple model of communication that
i will teach and others
that that looks at those elements it's
you have a sender and who is that sender
and who's the best sender what's the
message what's the appropriate channel
and what can you do to make the
likelihood that your message will
resonate the most with the receiver
and i hear you talking about all of
those elements for sure with one
addition and the one addition is i start
with so who's the audience because in a
in a startup there's multiple audiences
typically in your head is do i want to
reach the customers or do i want to
reach vcs or do i want to reach other
companies and what's confusing is when
you're trying to figure this out the way
i tend to say well time out you know
let's go back to our strategy
are we trying to reach customers or
investors or acquirers and and they're
very different audiences with each
requiring their own message media and
messengers and if you try to kind of put
them together you end up with a ball of
twine
so how do you figure out which one of
these are most important in what order
it turns out
if you remember we talked about the
business model if you drilled down on it
you kind of
understood that there were typically
multiple customer segments each one of
them with a who have their own pains
that they want solved or are looking for
solutions vcs are looking for hot deals
in this area corporate customers might
be looking for something very specific
and so to figure out who the audience is
you need to go back all the way to the
back to what's our strategy and
you know what's our business model the
second part is what's the message you
know i tend to think that messages
answer three questions you know why
should the audience care
what are you offering and more
importantly what's the call to action
the last one is to me like the most
important is like okay what do you want
them to do you want to pick up the phone
or click here or do something else or
are you just trying to kind of get into
their heads then you could own a space
now what's nice is if you've been doing
some of this customer development that's
getting out of the building
this is a big idea is that your
customers have already told you how to
craft the first part of the message that
is why why they should care
um that comes directly from the
if you've done customer development
correctly they've told you what their
pains and gains are
if you haven't done any of this getting
out of the building then you're staring
at a blank sheet of paper going well i
wonder what they care about many things
you've said are absolutely critical to
all types of communication you have to
know your audience you have to
understand what's relevant to them then
you have to craft messages that are
tailored to that audience that are in
service of the broader strategy and one
key point that i really want to echo for
everybody to to really internalize is
you have to adjust and adapt the message
for that audience it is so often that
people try to create one pitch deck or
one message and then spread it among
multiple audiences and and that's where
you dilute the message and you can
actually confuse the people you're
talking to so that point you may
all the points were valuable but that
one in particular i wanted to highlight
there's a couple more things about the
message that i run into all the time
with this particularly entrepreneurs
coming out of a technical world
is what are you offering and almost
always they start with the feature list
you know here here are all the bullets
and here's why we're doing x or y and i
just kind of shut them down i go wait a
minute if we've gotten out of the
building and talk to customers we should
know what's important to them it's not
the feature list but you know what
relieves pain or creates gain for them
and again if you're just sitting in the
building staring at a blank sheet to
paper you're not going to have a clue
but if you've talked to them you would
have known it and then finally the call
to action as i said you know what do you
want them to do the other thing is
context
for messages a message that's brilliant
today might be
met with blank stairs two years ago or
two years from now
so remember you know that all messages
operate in context that sometimes have
an expiration date
and then finally messages need to be
memorable they need to be sticky because
the more memorable the message the
greater its ability to create change
the classic analogy is consider if you
were told you were going to pay for cold
dead fish wrapped at seaweed you might
not be too hungry but but when we call
it sushi people line up and pay lots of
money so that's that's my enough about
message matt back to you what i'm
hearing you say about messages are so
many valuable things one it has to be
tailored to an audience and their
specific needs
second it should not just be a list of
features it needs to be value and
relevance
bullets kill don't kill your audience
with bullet points you must consider the
context as well and the context in which
the message is delivered can change
dramatically and then finally your last
point was we need to make it memorable
so it sticks and that has to do with not
only relevance but the words you use the
framing you use etc all of that is such
valuable advice thank you and matt the
last two points uh you know if i go back
where media messengers you know media
today is you know when i was an
entrepreneur media we used to cut down
dead trees and put ink on them or or you
know people used to have antennas on
their roofs and watch
broadcast tv you know today we just kind
of think of social media but but there
you need to have a a media mix it's
likely that each audience reads
different media you know potential
customers reach something different than
potential investors you need to have a
media strategy and that's a plan that
describes the mix of media and how you
use it and by the way the media to me
also includes your website your facebook
page your twitter page etc
it should be the first place that you
experiment finding your audience and
messengers and then the last part is
messengers
and these are kind of the well-placed
and highly leveraged individuals who
influence your audience and i'm not
talking about your ceo i'm talking about
you know who's respected in that
industry that's now
you've actually given them your
powerpoint slide and they they're using
it to diagram the space or
you know messengers are the one who
convey and amplify your message to your
audience through the media you've chosen
and so you know some types of messengers
for example are reporters industry
experts evangelists connectors and each
audience has their own unique set of
messengers and some of them nowadays on
social media or can be bought like
influencers so you could actually pay
for some messengers as well
and depending on your industry and what
you're trying to achieve you know the
messengers will vary
very widely very useful reminders there
that
your communication is not just the
messages that you create it's the media
and channels through which you release
them and it's the messengers who act on
your behalf to amplify and spread them
very very important so before we end i'd
like to ask you the same three questions
i ask everyone who joins me you okay
with that
sure all right here we go
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title
what would it be
well you know it's the one i kind of
lived on is uh
any idiot can make a complicated thing
sound complicated it takes real skill to
make it sound simple so it takes real
skill to make something sound simple
absolutely we we've spent a lot of time
on this podcast with many guests talking
about how to make complex information
accessible to an audience it's not about
dumbing it down it's about making it
relevant and and putting it in into
terms that people can understand
let me ask you question number two
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
the individual communicator obviously
again i grew up in the world of the 20th
century steve jobs in the 21st century
steve jobs
probably the best in my mind about being
able to create a reality distortion
field that made you want to throw out a
perfectly good product every year and
buy the next one you know steve jobs
reinvented the 20th century
automobile model change it used to be in
the 50s and 60s people would stand in
line to see the
next year's car model hard to believe
now and actually buy it because it had
bigger tail fins or you know like
flashier chrome steve jobs essentially
resurrected that idea and managed to
convince people that
the last year's iphone that they loved
is completely obsolete but you should
still love the company because this one
has like a flashier feature the phrase
was planned obsolescent and at the same
time obviously was able to communicate
the benefits of new product
breakthroughs like ipod and iphone and
etc final question
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe you know i mentioned kind of the
audience messenger message etc but i
guess i would tell you something
different to kind of just put a cap on
it
if the ceo thinks this is a tactic there
isn't going to be a
successful communication recipe
if the ceo thinks it's a strategy an
integral and a force multiplier for the
company
then there's going to be a successful
route a communication strategy and
recipient right so it's really the
investment and focus on communication so
many entrepreneurs see communication as
a necessary evil rather than something
that that really needs to have some deep
strategy behind it thank you so much
your insights perspectives and passion
are incredibly helpful and motivational
i've thoroughly enjoyed our time
together and all of us have learned a
lot from your experience thank you well
thank you matt i learned a lot actually
when you asked the question well
excellent thank you
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts